let's let's have a look so it's it's
another joker piano
uh this this opening that it's
it's become the kind of go-to opening
for the elite guys hasn't it
and going in for this setup uh with
bishop c5 of course instead of d3 there
are all those crazy lines that white has
got with knight g5
but that's a different theory we see the
italians so many times at top level
at the elite level at all levels really
and now this is one idea with rookie one
allowing
knight g4 hitting that pawn on f2 which
i always would be happy to get with the
black pieces
uh very often what black does here is
also try and get knight eight six
move away the king and go f5 let's do
this
and see what happens so you like king h8
right i like king h8 so that when you
play h3 to push my knight away i'm going
to go knight eight six and i'm going
f5 next we have it on the boat by the
way rookie two he is going for king h8
so this typical idea
when one doesn't play h3 to stop knight
g4 it always gives black this
opportunity to go f5
we're going to be seeing this meanwhile
dani i asked chad what they are rooting
for
between anish and magnus and lots of
anish for the win in the chat here and
well we got another rook on a2 this time
somehow over protecting here um
and that is on the board so d4 has shot
out the bishop on a7 for the moment
this is this is what i call the belt and
braces approach
he's making absolutely certain that
nothing is going to happen on f2
well this is fascinating interesting
that he didn't develop the
the queen's bishop but that's how he's
bringing the queen's rook into play
here you know there's a kind of classic
exchange sacrifice here
um but i don't see that there's a good
follow-up because
a very interesting sacrifice immediately
but maybe to start with either queen g6
or knight g6 has a direct threat now
that that certainly looks more
responsible
so if i play um i mean i'm assuming that
i'm not going to take here because of
because of the sound so i'll play knight
g3 right yeah knight g3 looks
a lot more reasonable d takes e5 you
take rook f3 and then you think you
don't even blink before taking on f3
sure
and there's a pin here of course now i'm
still i'm still
eyeing the sacrifice just just for fun
listen let me do it and let's let's find
out let's do it
okay and then i'm going to put the
knight back here i really don't want to
take on e5 even if i end up winning a
pawn with white here because
activating that bishop on a7 is a very
scary thought
okay i'm gonna do it okay that was
actually very nice prophylaxis playing
rook day two to cover f2
actually white's queen can enter very
quickly
and it feels like white is kind of
coordinated enough so all right
i think the exchange sacrifice looks a
bit bonkers
he goes for knight g6 and i think that
also makes a lot of sense it's also a
preparatory move when you take on f3
maybe a knight is going to jump to
h4 at some point and also i is the
knight is the square on f4 knight f4 is
a big threat
as well i like the move knight g6 just
gonna play knight g3
and just say all right you know if you
want to take it
fine but actually white is pretty well
coordinated here
now again there's no immediate threat
from black
so i wonder whether it's time
can we throw in a queen d5 maybe
let's let's play queen d5 and and that
that hits a couple of lumps here
okay i'm going to be very brave and take
this i mean i
can't imagine that anything like this
will happen but you know
they're protecting f2 very very well i
have a feeling that
magnus is actually okay i mean when i
say okay i
mean more than okay yeah well
interesting magnus has played c4
now that means that he's definitely
didn't want to allow that
uh his pawns to be broken up fascinating
move actually
because it does mean that he can
actually close that bishop off with c5
as well
very interesting idea can't black now
just sidestep with the queen go queen f7
okay yeah now there's knight g5
not so scared about it for some reason
not so scared okay then i'm going to
play it
yeah you go for it you provoked me i
walked you by saying that
definitely yeah that's gotta move away
with the queen
where do we go so queen f5 okay let's
let's have a little look so queen f5
well i've also got knight g3 to push the
queen away again
i do want to play queen h3 come on i've
got to threaten that [ __ ]
i'm just hoping that i can get knight f4
in now is that possible
um that if you can then yes i
well i've got to take it you've got to
take it i take it with the pawn
yes now
this one is attacked so what knight
96 i guess well we're having fun here
who's better and why i have no idea and
and black decides to go for none of
these complications he doesn't go queen
f7 i think knight g5 was definitely an
idea there
and especially after queen f5 there was
knight g3 instead anish chooses the move
e4
hitting that knight on f3 but because
the pawn is still pinned white doesn't
need to save it just yet he goes knight
g3
putting pressure on the e4 pawn
[Music]
sweet sacrifice here we go we've got a
big
this is fun this is fun are you not
entertained
oh this is great stuff and i think anish
had to do this actually because i'm
looking at this position i'm thinking
well
hang on this has gone really badly wrong
for black but
he's cut the gordian knot and
sacrificed his queen and now don't
forget our beautiful bishop on h
on a7 might miraculously come into the
game
wow this is scary and magnus down
two minutes if the key then another
check on h4 don't forget knight h4 and
exactly that's i hadn't forgotten it at
all it's
really really scary but what is going on
because
maybe you can get away with this because
can we take this knight
uh i mean this requires some
serious calculation also there was rook
f3 at that moment
and instead of all of that magnus
decides to come back with the queen to
d1 he says i'm not going to allow your
rook to jump into e1
and anish immediately blitzing out the
move knight h4
keeping the pressure going there really
now he's targeting the g2 pawn
knight takes g2 rookie one would be a
big threat also
f takes g2 in the air how
you know what dani i don't even care
what the what the eval bar says about
the position
i think this is a nightmare for magnus
yeah this is this looks
really scary of course the move you want
to make is rookie 2 to challenge but
with the pawn on f3 absolutely
impossible yeah i mean this
is a lot of fun for uh a niche to play
and
it looks to me like it's it's turning in
his direction absolutely
it's a square so this allows rookie one
jack danny look he wants
one oh he's just is this uh
is it not over yet knight takes h2
you can pick up so many pawns you can
give a check on h2 as well
take on d4 okay it's it's already very
very good
and just take a look at the players
anish is so tuned into the position
right now complete focus there he knows
that this is a big moment he can feel it
he can feel the pressure that he's built
uh he takes on g2 and
and big threats on the board rookie one
is coming in
rookie one queenie one knight f3 is the
idea here
queen g4 uh you take you go rookie one
and king h2 you just queen and that's
over oh my god
yeah wow so so he's what
what it's gone rook
e okay let's just just here we go
so takes rook e2 makes a lot of sense so
it stops rookie one from coming in you
trade off the rook
and now um this looks so scary
and magnus is now thinking queen takes
he doesn't have time though he's down to
24 seconds and knight takes f2
uh knight h3 queening that g2 pawn
danny i think anisha is going to do it i
think he's going to win this game
i think so because because if magnus
takes here
then this end game is of course
completely well it's winning instantly
on the spot um and yeah knight
h3 is happening wow what a turn up
bishop e3
magnus is fighting but how are you
fighting
knight takes h3 king h2
it looks terrible but where's the wind
danny
oh okay is there a win i think we can
actually just do this
let's have a look here takes takes
here bishop takes and i think we're
going to win the queen
rook f2 but you go king h1 you go king
h1
king h1 instead uh
no win still looks i mean listen we've
got rook and a bishop and three pawns
and the king is in big trouble
but maybe nothing immediate let's have a
look this is on the board by the way
this position is on the board i have a
feeling
there is something here i mean worst
case this is not a bad situation to be
in
just just making a queen there by the
way i'm not i'm not
finding anything better than that
because you can't go knight f3 because
the g2 pawn is hanging
the knight on h3 is threatened currently
so you don't have time for a move like
do you have time for a move like rook e8
rook e8 uh so i
take i was hoping to get in g1
oh but that doesn't work i'm not
counting correctly you're just a piece
up at the end no
or no no no no okay so let's let's do
this
takes and black is lo
is two pawns up danny let's keep up with
the live boat because the players have
got no time at all he decides to go for
your line he queens with g1 and i think
i think rookie 8 was was a very
interesting option actually
however i mean well as i said before
this
looks absolutely playable for black and
i would suggest probably winning as well
oh he's gone
he's gone knight f3 he's gone knight f3
and the king has come back and queen e7
danny i saw the evaluation bar jump
straight back up to a level game after
knight f3 i think knight f3 was a big
mistake by anish
okay because now has he got knights has
he got knight g
oh my name g86 queen f6
brilliant brilliant magnus survives and
take a look at that that's a very
relieved magnus and a very disappointed
anishi was so close to getting this one
what a game that that is a fantastic
save from magnus